bekommen eine Situation die wir nicht
meistern können wir schaffen das
schlicht nicht mehr so muss man das
formulieren und dann muss man auch damit
umgehen dass der Neubau von
Sozialwohnungen der ja gerade eher
einbricht als zunimmt dass der viele
Jahre dauern wird also Ehrlichkeit
gegenüber der Bevölkerung zu sagen das
Problem werden die Kommunen euch nicht
lösen können dann wird die Unterbringung
leider je mehr kommen umso häufiger so
sein wie das gerade von ihnen gehört
haben in opal und die Zahl die jetzt die
ersten beiden Monate sind lässt seine
Prognose von 400.000 dieses Jahr
durchaus zu scheint nicht übertrieben zu
sein 400 000 wird noch viele opatz
schaffen das sollte man im Bund erkennen
und deswegen ist auch Ordnung in der
Flüchtlingspolitik eine Forderung von
der wir nicht abgehen können